if you thought neutron stars were big
and scary well you haven't heard of
their more powerful Stellar cousins yet
like neutron stars magnetars are
leftovers from Supernova explosions
they're just packed with a lot more
matter
their density is so high that a single
teaspoon of a magnetar could weigh in at
a billion tons
they're also the most magnetic Stars we
know about
we use a unit called a Gauss to measure
the strength of a magnetic field Earth's
magnetic field is only about 0.6 Gauss
this is the most powerful object in the
universe the magnetic field of a
magnetar can be as strong as one
quadrillion Gauss
how long would it take a stellar monster
like that to rip our planet apart